Das Podcast-Ufo landet weich im nächstgelegenen Gartenteich, wir alle machen uns bereit.
Ein wirrer WC, Entenschwan, zieht direkt daneben seine Bahn, wir alle machen uns bereit.
Es geht um Comedy, es geht um Comedy, jetzt sprechen Florentin und Stefan,
es geht um Comedy, es geht um Comedy, jetzt sprechen Florentin und Stefan.
Die Welt bleibt stehen, wir lauschen still, Stefan T, jetzt sprechen Florentin und Stefan.
Die Welt bleibt stehen, wir lauschen still, Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will.
Herzlich willkommen zu der neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast-Uf, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze und dein Name ist Florentin Will.
Ja, fast hätte ich meinen Namen selber sagen müssen. Hallo Stefan, schön, dass du mit dabei bist, herzlich willkommen.
Wir haben die Gruselwoche überstanden zum Glück.
Ja, und merkt man ja schon im Intro, wir kommen in so eine Weihnachtsecke, in so eine, wir rezitieren Dinge, wir hören uns Gedichte an, schreibt uns Gedichte. Es wird endlich wieder besinnlich und damit natürlich auch herzlichen Dank an Caroline, die uns hier die Hand gereicht hat in diese herrliche besinnliche Jahreszeit, obwohl ich sagen muss, geben sich Leute eigentlich überhaupt gar keine Mühe mehr? Kinder Bueno zum Beispiel. Caroline hat sich doch Mühe gegeben. Ja, Caroline schon, aber ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl, sie ist die Letzte, die sich noch Mühe gibt.
Heute im Supermarkt gesehen,
Bueno, natürlich eine fantastische Marke, lecker,
schmackhaft, aber nicht
feiertagstauglich, dachtest du?
Nein, ehrlich gesagt,
kannst du so einem Bueno-Riegel eine
Zipfelmütze aufsetzen? Nein.
Kannst du ihm so Fledermausflügel
annähen für Halloween? Nein.
Doch jetzt hat Doktor Kinder
eine Idee gehabt. Und zwar bringen sie raus zu Weihnachten. Du klingst, du redest so wie so ein Moderator, der das, wie so ein Beitrag für so ein Mittagsmagazin. Man hört gar nicht mehr zu, man denkt, wo ist der Beitrag? Hau die Matz raus, wo ist sie? Aber sie kommt nie. Im Grunde ist Podcast eine lange Anmoderation für diese eine Matz, die ihr gemacht. Fürs Outro. Und deswegen hat sich Doktor Kinder überlegt, natürlich, wir bringen zu Weihnachten raus die Bueno Eggs. Eier. Wie gross sind die? Kleines Ei. Ungefähr ein bisschen so gross wie ein Schubbrauch. Und das Überraschungsei sagt so, Leute, I'm standing right here. Direkt, ich habe eine Überraschung drin und bin größer. Hallo, ich bin ein fucking Ei. Es gibt schon Eier. Und ich denke mir, hallo, es gibt zwei Feiertage, wo Schokolade eine große Rolle spielt, Ostern und Weihnachten, und die entscheiden sich, zu Weihnachten die Eier rauszubringen. Wie unglaublich zukunftsfremd kann man sein? Die werden ein riesiges Problem haben zu Ostern, weil sie denken, ja scheiße, die Eier haben wir jetzt schon zu Weihnachten gebracht. Weißt du was, ich glaube nämlich, das ist da so eine, da sind so Finanzheilis dahinter und das wird einfach eins zu eins auch als Osterei herausgegeben und die haben jetzt einmal diese Maschinen gekauft, diese riesigen Dampfmaschinen, wo dann so Kohle reingeschäufelt wird und so Haare von Waisenkindern. Genau, Haare von Waisenkindern. Alles muss verbrannt werden.
Füsschen von Babys. Und dann kommt oben ein Dampf raus, schwarzer Dampf. Und so Trolle schieben so große Zahnräder. Die so gepeitscht werden von diesem grinsenden Jungen von der Kinderpackung. Genau. Weiter, los! Ganz viele kleine, weisse, blonde Jungs, die dann so Riesentrolle peitschen und dann plötzlich haben die aber halt nur eine
Maschine gekauft mit diesem Ei.
Genau. Die wollten nur einmal investieren.
Die haben nicht gesagt, nee, wir machen auch noch die Weihnachtsgans
Form,
sondern Ei.
Ei ist auch billig, weil es von beiden Seiten
gleich reicht, es reicht quasi nur eine Hälfte.
Die Maschine muss nur die Hälfte leisten.
Ich habe nichts gegen die Eiforne. Ich glaube, da hast du mich jetzt völlig falsch verstanden. Sorry. Ich habe überhaupt nichts. Habe ich mich verrannt? Du hast mich ein bisschen verrannt. Ich habe überhaupt gar nichts gegen die iPhone an sich. Ich glaube nur, es ist ein bisschen... Zu Weihnachten hast du doch... Es ist einfach albern, das zu Weihnachten rauszubringen. Aber dann hast du was gegen die iPhone. Nee, ich habe was gegen die iPhone zu Weihnachten. Die iPhone an Ostern ist super. Ich glaube ohnehin, dass der Trend in diese Richtung geht. Wobei auch das möchte ich mal in Frage stellen. Die Eiform an Ostern, was war zuerst da? Der Oster, die Egg oder der Osterhase? Das ist eine gute Frage. Wenn der Osterhase zuerst da war. Hase oder das Ei? Vor allem ein hochbibligisches Fest, wo kommt dieser Osterhase her, we don't know, wo kommt das Ei her, wir sind auch nicht so ganz. Wenn aber zuerst der Hase da war, finde ich, das Ei mindestens genauso fragt wie an Weihnachten.
Und dann denke ich mir, dann macht's auch an Weihnachten.
Die machen immer das gleiche Problem.
Die machen immer das gleiche Problem. Diese ganzen
dummen Eier, egal zu Ostern oder zu Weihnachten,
sind viel zu krass verpackt. Kennst du die,
die wirklich mit dieser Alu
wirklich eingeschweißt, wo die
unter hydraulischen Druckpressenmaschinen,
wo zehn von diesen kleinen, blonden
Kindern sich draufstemmen müssen, um die so wirklich zu verpacken, dass du die wirklich auch überwintern kannst und die sind noch frisch. Ja, in den Minien von Barthalomir, wo die dann hundert Jahre lang gepresst und geschweißt und doppelt verglast werden. Du, ich verstehe, dass du nicht willst, dass die kleinen Jungs, die das Ganze einpacken müssen, dass sie die gar nicht essen können, deswegen werden die so verpackt. Ich verstehe schon, dass sie hungern müssen, damit die richtig arbeiten können. Ich verstehe das ja, diese kapitalistische Logik, ich habe das ja drin, das passt ja alles, kein Problem. Aber hat man denn gar nichts vom fucking Schokobon gelernt? Es ist, dass die Lösung auf der Hand liegt. Ja, das Schokobon ist deswegen so erfolgreich, weil du es leicht aufmachen kannst. Stell dir vor, Schokobons in dieser Alu-Verpackung, Flop. These, Schok Schokobons sind eher eiförmig als bonbonförmig. Ja, weiter, mehr, mehr, ich habe jetzt den Kanal abonniert, so ein Kleinkind, das hinter der Mutter so schüchtern wird, nein, ich habe den Kanal abonniert, ich habe die Glocke geklickt, alles, ich habe den Sub, ich habe einen Kombi dagelassen, jetzt kommt gar nichts mehr. One and Wonder. Klassisches, das war meine eine Idee für meinen YouTube-Kanal. Schokobon eiförmig. Aber ich glaube, Schokobon ist deswegen so erfolgreich, weil du es einfach schnell wegsnacken kannst, weiss einfach. Und sie sagen dir das Geheimnis mit einem Hubs in siehe Mund, Leute, hört doch einfach zu. Es ist doch nicht so schwer. Hört die Signale! Ich meine, es ist selten, dass wirklich Firmen und Produkte dir die die Geheimnisse direkt im Werbeklaim sagen, die sagen auch nicht, Malboro, es sind die Chemikalien, die da drin sind, sagen die auch nicht. Da, Schokobau ist das einzige Produkt, das dir sagt, warum es so erfolgreich ist. Möchtest du mir mal kurz verraten, was the most overrated und most underrated Kinderprodukt ist? Oh! Für mich ist nämlich das, most overrated ist Kinder Country. Ähm, finde ich so, ich finde es einfach langweilig, ähm, nicht wirklich lecker, es ist nicht so wirklich so ein Schoko-Flash, den du bekommst, und so, es ist vor allem, es kombiniert die schlechtesten Dinge von Kinderprodukten, eine okaye Vollmilchschokolade mit diesem Milchersatzprodukt. Es ist immer die gleiche Vollmilchschokolade, die immer nur okay ist. Das ist ja eigentlich, finde ich, die Kernfrage im Kinder-Universe. Was ist alles gleich? Es gibt Theorien zum Beispiel, dass die Hanuta-Creme das gleiche ist wie die Raffaello-Creme. Aber jetzt wird gerade Ferreiro und Doktor Kinder und Ferreiro machst du gerade durchs Dureinander. Nein, ich meine, Captain Oetker und Doktor Igloo sind im gleichen Universum. Nein, nein. Was in den Fischstäbchen drin ist... Nein, was in den Fischstäbchen drin ist, ist das gleiche, wie was in Raffaello drin ist. Okay, das ist klar. Es ist keine Schokolade, das wissen wir. Aber was zur Hölle ist es dann? Und warum ist es auch in den Fischstäbchen drin? Also, weil ich finde nämlich, die Stärke von Kinder liegt nicht, und jetzt weiß ich, die Drohbriefe flottern ins Haus, die Schokolade. Mit bunten Wachsmalschreide gemalten Presserbriefe. Ja, und so ganz kleinen, so Abdrücken, so Hände abdrücken und so Silhouettenbilder. Nein, die Stärke ist nicht die Schokolade. Deswegen mein most underrated Kinderprodukt ist nämlich das Schokofresh. Denn genau diese Nuss-Nougat-Creme in Verbindung mit diesem leichten Milchschaum, der, glaube ich, nie Milch gesehen hat. Und jetzt, da macht die Schokolade Sinn. Diese sehr milde, forgettable Schokolade, again, sorry, die ist da nicht so wirklich im Mittelpunkt. Die ist nur, die außen sorgt für den Knusper-Knackfaktor. Aber drinnen hast du die Nougat-Creme, und die ist geil, und das kann Kindergut, und das kenne ich nicht besser. Deswegen ist Bueno am besten und Schokofrisch am besten. Ich würde sagen, Overrated sind alle Eise, alle Kindereise, Eisen, Eises, Eises, Ich kenne kein Kindereis, Kindereis, alle Kindereise, ja es gab eine Zeit, wo alle jauchzend zum Tiefkühlregal gesprungen sind und dachten, okay es gibt jetzt das Bueno-Eis, es gibt das Kinderriegeleis, es gibt alle Eise, aber alle waren enttäuschend. Alle waren enttäuschend, deswegen most overrated auf jeden Fall die Eise. Underrated würde ich sagen Kinderkarte, die Karte mit Waffel. Ich bin ja ein Waffelfreund. Du bist mal ein Freund. Ich greife doch gern zur Waffel. Als Waffelfreund verstehe ich das, okay, gut. Aber da haben wir es geklärt, da haben wir es jetzt einfach einmal geklärt. Okay, wunderbar. Legen wir das Thema auf die Seite. Haben wir das auch geklärt. Hast du dich gegruselt? Ich habe mich ein bisschen gegruselt, ich habe noch viele Horrorfilme geschaut, ich habe die Horrorsaison eingeläutet, Halloween war eine riesen Enttäuschung, ich wollte verkleidet rausgehen, alle waren krank und oder hatten keine Zeit oder Lust auf Halloween. Wie keine Zeit an Halloween, was macht man an Halloween, was muss ich Steuer machen jetzt? Viele waren im Urlaub. Mhm, auch nicht in Transsilvanien. Viele waren im Transsilvanien im Urlaub, ich hätte da mal richtig Bock drauf, und so eine, und das ist in Deutschland glaube ich nie so verbreitet, wie es, aber again, weiß ich auch nicht, bin ich tief im Thema drin, aber in Amerika gibt es ja diese Haunted Houses überall. Ja. Und da gibt es dann auch halt Schauspieler, ganz viele Schauspieler, deren einziger Job ist, ganzjährig in diesem so Haunted Houses zu arbeiten und Leute zu erschrecken. Also das ist für mich die furchtbarste Vorstellung von allen. Und hier in Köln gab es auch ein Haunted House, habe es aber nicht geschafft, da hinzukommen. Cologne Dungeon. The Cologne Dungeon. Nee, aber es ist eben nicht so, nicht so. Es sind wirklich so abseitige, alte Heilsanstalten, Nervenheilanstalten. Ach so, okay. Wo dann, die wirklich früher sowas waren, so ein bisschen, da wird mit der Geschichte was gemacht. Da werden so viele alte Bunker in Deutschland. Keine Ahnung, wo die herkommen. Ich kenne mich nicht gut mit der Geschichte aus. Nee, ich auch nicht. Wer hat mit den großen Drachenkriegen. Aber da könnte man doch wirklich viel damit machen, oder nicht? Mal so einen richtigen Horrorbunker oder so. Es kommt, glaube ich, den Bunkern zum Nachteil, dass sie relativ boring sind. Mhm. Nicht? Ja, gut, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt an dieses klassische Horrorkrankenhaus denkst, ein Krankenhaus ist auch langweilig. Korridore, so immer die gleichen Räume oder so. Aber da kannst du so Geschichten jetzt. Ja gut, da kannst du dir auch alles ausdenken. Ist es nicht das, also Horror plus Nazi-Nostalgie ist es nicht perfekt, so einen Horrorbunker zu machen oder so? Mhm, Nazi-Zombies. Nazi-Zombies, perfekt. Ist wirklich perfekt. Ich würde da echt mal drüber nachdenken, irgendwo so, in Berchtesgaden oder so, wo es irgendwie noch so viele Sachen davon gibt. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich hasse ja Horrorfilme, habe mich dieses Jahr aber versucht, ran zu robben, langsam, und eine folgende Strategie. Kissen, Riesenkissen. Ich hatte ein Kissen in gewisser Weise, ein Kissen in Tapform, und zwar hatte ich immer ein Tap offen mit Anchorman. Ah ja. Und ich habe immer, wenn der Horrorfilm mir zu gruselig wurde, habe ich ein bisschen Anchorman geguckt und wenn es wieder ging, habe ich wieder einen Horrorfilm geguckt. Was letzten Endes dazu geführt hat, dass sich jetzt Angst vor Anchorman hat und dass ich Horrorfilme lustig finde. Also es hat irgendwie in meinem Kopf irgendwie die falschen Verbindungen geschlossen. Also irgendwie bin ich jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt. Also findest du das Comedy gruselig? Ich finde das Comedy gruselig.
Das wollten wir ja nicht. Nee, das wollten wir ja gar nicht.
Aber wie lange hast du
durchschnittlich gebraucht,
beim Anchorman gucken, um wieder im Modus
zu sein, sich einen Horrorfilm einzulassen?
Schon lang. Schon so 20 Minuten.
Wie oft hast du Anchorman während It Fall Out
geschaut?
Dreimal. Es war ein langer Abend.
Es war ein langer Abend. Es war ein langer Abend.
Ich meine, es gibt Enkeman 1, Enkeman 2 und dann noch
die Miniseries habe ich alle durchgeballert,
dann die Zeichentricks, Spin-Offs,
dann die ganzen Werbungen habe ich alle gesehen.
Rogue One, hast du alles gesehen?
Genau, Enke One.
Aber okay, welche Horrorfilme
machst du dich, an welcher hast du dich getraut?
Ich habe jetzt hier, Guillermo del Toro
hat ja auf Netflix diese
Horror-Anthologie-Serie und
da habe ich reingeguckt und
Vielen Dank. und an dich hast du dich getraut. Ich hab jetzt hier, Guillermo del Toro hat ja auf Netflix diese Horror- Anthologie-Serie und da hab ich reingeguckt und gruselig, gruselig, schaurig, schaurig, klapper, klapper, klapper und da kommt der Geist und ja, war auf jeden Fall eine wilde Zeit. Aber das ist ja auch so das Ding, irgendwann so diese ganzen Techniken kommen dann so ein bisschen wieder auf einen zurück. Wenn du irgendwie immer beim Zahnarzt versuchst, so irgendwie immer an den Strand zu denken, um dich zu entspannen. Und wenn du dann am Strand bist, dann hast du das Bohren im Horror, weil du immer Strand und Zahnarzt verbindest. Und du denkst dir, fuck, nicht nur hat es nicht funktioniert beim Zahnarzt, sondern ich habe mir auch Strände ruiniert. In gewisser Weise leben wir halt alle falsch. Weiter? In dem Moment, wo du ... Hot Takes, ist das der größte Hot Take, den man machen kann? Ja. Okay, tu es. Hot Take, alle Hot Takes sind falsch. Aber ich denke mir, wenn wir alle etwas machen, während wir eigentlich ... Also beim Sport. Wir machen alle Sport, alle hören aber eigentlich Musik dabei. Ja, wir machen alle Sport, ne? Jeder.
Die meisten Leute machen,
zwingen sich... Ich glaube, das kannst alle sagen.
Also ich habe nichts dagegen, dass du alle sagst. Die meisten zwingen sich ab und zu zum Sport
und hören aber eigentlich dabei Musik.
Das ist ja ein bisschen wie, du bist beim Zahnarzt,
aber denkst du an was Schönes, um es irgendwie rumzubekommen.
Wir sind immer mit, du,
alle gucken Horrorfilme und haben nebenbei, gucken
Angerman. Alle machen nebenbei was anderes. Ja mach doch eigentlich das, was ihr wollt, denke ich mir. Weiter? Also du meinst, wenn du beim Zahnarzt bist, musst du dich voll auf den Zahnarzt konzentrieren. Nee, wenn du ... Keine Fluchtmöglichkeit, kein Notausgang. Wenn du beim Zahnarzt an den Strand denken musst, geh doch zum Strand. Geh nicht zum Zahnarzt. Wenn du beim Sport lieber Musik hörst, dann hör doch einfach Musik. Wir machen keinen Sport. Wenn du beim Film gucken lieber Popcorn-Snacks, dann mach doch das als Hauptbeschäft. Wenn du immer was anderes machen musst, um die Situation auszuhalten, dann mach doch das andere, was ihr eigentlich machen wollt. Und wann gehe ich dann zum Zahnarzt? Also weil dann, immer wenn ich zum Zahnarzt gehen würde, gehe ich städtisch zum Strand, dann... Nee, du gehst nicht zum Zahnarzt, weil du hast ja... Hört auf, Dinge zu machen, die euch keinen Spaß machen. Hört auf, Dinge, okay, zu machen, die euch keinen Spaß machen. Okay, ja, fähig wieder ganz ansatz. Was ich noch nicht dachte, wo wir gerade bei steilen Thesen sind, ähm, ich habe All Quiet on the Western Front geguckt, im Westen nichts Neues, ähm, Filmtipp, ähm, alter Film fand ich noch besser, aber der neue ist auch toll. Und wen hast du nicht gesehen in dem Film? Uns. Stimmt, wir haben uns beworben damals, richtig. Wir haben uns beworben als Statisten. Im Westen nichts Neues, wir wollten irgendwie so ein Soldat im Hintergrund sein, so ein Botengänger, der die Hauptfigur dann irgendwie so einen matschigen Zettel überreicht, mit irgendwie, wir müssen uns zurückziehen oder was auch immer. Nichts, bis heute nichts. Hier, von Leutnant Grubenhübel. Ja, schnell, die Franzosen kommen. Das heißt, ich hoffe sehr auf die fucking Deleted-Scenes, wenn die rauskommen, dass sich da irgendwo uns beide sehen, auf die Outtakes. Du hättest beim Dreh dabei sein müssen. Aber bei den Deleted-Scenes doch nicht, die kommen doch noch. Die wurden, Florentin, die Deleted-Scenes dreht man doch und dann verliert man die im Schnittraum wahrscheinlich. Nee, die macht man für die DVD, drehen die Deleted-Scenes, damit da mehr ist. Florentin, nein, so läuft das der Film nicht. Doch natürlich, und dann später die Outtakes. Du hast in Produktionen mitgespielt, du weißt, wie es läuft. Moment mal, das heißt, wir sind nicht im Film. Wir sind nicht dabei, wir sind nicht bei All Quiet on the Western Side of the Front, of the War. Wir sind nicht dabei. Okay. Ja, ich weiß, dass es scheiße ist, aber hey, komm, hey, bei Teil zwei sind wir dabei.
Eigentlich hätten wir sagen sollen, dass wir dabei sind.
Too quiet on the western front.
Way too quiet.
Und offensichtlich ist es in zwei.
A little bit more noisy.
Way too quiet on the western front.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Aber eigentlich hätten wir sagen sollen, dass wir dabei sind und im Podcast so erzählen sollen, boah, wir waren heute am Set, mega geil, ich bin noch voller Schmutz, boah, Stefan hat da irgendwie so eine Rauchexplosion ins Gesicht bekommen. Halt das Auge verloren, krass. Und dann schauen alle den Film und suchen nach uns und finden uns nicht. Vielleicht würden sie uns finden und sagen, ah, ich habe dich gefunden, Stefan, und dann irgendein Bild von so einem Random-Typen. Und da haben sie gesagt, viele schlaue Sachen werden in dem Film gesagt, das Buch ist übrigens noch viel besser, lest das Buch. Und da sind ganz tolle Dialoge, die noch mal klar machen, was schon klar ist, aber was dann noch mal anschaulich gemacht wird. Kriege sind absolut bescheuert. Und dann hab ich gedacht ... War bescheuert das Wort, das Sie benutzt haben? Dusselig. Und dann hab ich überlegt, wie wär's denn, wenn wir uns einigen, alle Länder der Welt ... Es ist ja unrealistisch, jetzt Kriege abzuschaffen. Es gibt immer Konflikte, es wird immer Kriege geben. Und ... das macht keinen Sinn, darüber nachzudenken, über eine Utopie, wo es das nicht mehr gibt. Aber angenommen, wir einigen uns auf so was wie ... Pinball. Ja. Oder Tetris. Okay, also du meinst, alle Kriege werden ab jetzt durch Pinball. Genau, also alle Waffen, die es gibt auf der Welt und Kriegsmaschinerie und so, wird ins Weltall geschickt. Wird so verpackt. Oh, du willst den Alien uns unsere Waffen geben? Hoi! Ja, oder den Erdkern. Very noisy at the Spacefront, würde ich sagen, mein Lieber. So heißt das Sequel dann. Viel zu laut im Weltall. Im Westen zu viel Neues. Ja. Schmeißen wir es in das Land, in Marianngraben. Stell dir einfach vor, häng dich da rein ins Jahr. Stell dir einfach vor, dass alle Waffen wechseln. Wer wird die Fische uns angreifen oder was? Da kannst du jetzt sagen, wir wollen Paris einnehmen, wir greifen Frankreich an. Jetzt greifen wir die nicht aber an, physisch, und Soldaten müssen sterben, und Menschen müssen sterben, und Zivilisten müssen sterben, nein. Dann kann man Frankreich, und jetzt kann ja Deutschland aufrüsten, wäre jetzt einfach Leute Hardcore trainieren im Pinball. Das heißt, also stellt euch vor. Aber da hast du ja auch wieder so eine Rüstungsspirale. Dann würden die Franzosen ja sagen, wir brauchen jetzt Jacques Pinball, der dann noch besser wird. Richtig, genau. Doppelagenten, Megaagenten, krasse Agenten. Verstehe ich schon. Der hat diese Drücktechnik rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts. Genau, das heißt, es würde genauso viel Billiarden an Euros würde die EU in Grenzschützung, was auch immer, NATO, Ostfront reinpacken, aber das wäre halt in Training von Pinball-Leuten. Und dann, es geht genau gleiche Stakes, weil wie gesagt, die Stakes können wir uns nicht aussuchen, die machen die Menschen, die bringen wir mit. Homo homini lupus est. Wir kriegen, werden... Es ist kein Pinball in dem Zitat drin, das ist jetzt nicht... Genau. Pingus pongus ist der lateinische Begriff, es kommt nicht in diesem Zitat vor. Ich möchte nur sagen... Ich finde die Idee gut. Wir kriegen das nicht weg. Ich finde die Idee richtig gut. Wir können uns das nicht wegdenken, es wird es immer geben, es wird es immer geben. Und es wird immer, keine Ahnung, Quatsch, Quatsch, Gedanken geben in Menschen, wo man, ja, wo Dinge passieren, die wir furchtbar finden. Aber das können wir doch minimieren, wenn wir sagen, nee, es gibt es, es wird ein Pinball aufgetragen. Gut, aber Pinball ist jetzt ein Einzelspielerspiel. Ja, oder Paddel. Also du machst dann gegen Highscore, oder was? Also du sagst dann, okay, Frankreich stellt einen Highscore im Simpsons-Pinball auf und dann muss der deutsche Champion den Highscore knacken. Ja, oder sagen wir, oder Paddel. Zwei gegen zwei, boah. Zwei gegen zwei. Nee, da ist die Spionagegefahr viel zu hoch. Dann schmuggeln die einen, der absichtlich schlecht spielt einen. Das kannst du nicht machen. Das kannst du vergessen. Am Ende hast du da zwei Zweierteams, die beide versuchen, möglichst schlecht zu spielen. Wenn die Spionage viel zu krass ist und die wollen beide verlieren, weil es gibt es ja manchmal... Alle fragen sich, was passiert hier gerade. Es gibt es ja manchmal im Sport. Ja, aber hier im Eurovision Song Contents. Dass die Spiele gefixt sind, dass eine Mannschaft absichtlich verlieren will. Und ich denke mir, gab es in der Geschichte des Sports schon mal die Situation, dass beide Teams
gefixt waren und beide verlieren wollten
und beide dann mit Fussball immer nur so
Oh, Fehlpass.
Das habe ich ja jetzt
gedacht beim Schach,
bei dem Cheating-Skandal habe ich gedacht,
wie geil wäre es eigentlich, wenn jemand
eine Schach-Engine zum Cheaten
gegen jemanden,
der auch cheatet und eine Schach-Engine benutzt. Und plötzlich spielt einfach Stockfish 15 gegen Stockfish 15 dieses krasse Schachprogramm, krasse Schach-AI, Computer, neurales Netzwerk, bla bla bla. Und es entsteht einfach so eine mega weirde, unnachvollziehbare Engine gegen Engine, Elo 3300 gegen 3300 und niemand kann mehr folgen.
Und die Kommentatoren sind mega irritiert.
Okay, und warum haben Sie dann in Zug 822 hier die Dame F4 gespielt? Ja, weil sie jetzt nicht mehr. Ja gut, aber das war ein beeindruckender Zug. Sie müssten ja schon 138 Züge im Vorhinein gewusst haben, dass da genau der Bauer stehen würde. Ja, es war ja auch auf eine Art absehbar, dass früher oder später der D-Bauer da landet. Aha. Ich will jetzt auch ... My chest speaks for itself. My chest speaks ... Ja, genau. Und die Computer laufen so heiß, dass dann so diese Schuhsohlen, wo das dann übertragen wird mit Vibrationen, dass sich so anfangen zu brennen. Ich finde es auch albern, weil es gibt diesen Vorwurf, dass da ein Schachspieler gecheatet hat mit einem Computer, wo ich mir denke, Moment mal, wenn der mit einem Hochleistungscomputer gecheatet hätte, hätte ihm der Computer auch sagen können, wie er so cheaten kann, dass er nicht erwischt wird. Weil wenn es einen Schachcomputer gibt, muss es auch einen Cheatingcomputer geben. Du meinst der ... Der dann im Interview und dann so, haben Sie gecheatet? Nein. Okay. Aber wenn man das weiterdenkt, ist Hans Niemann ein Cyborg. Der ist so Ex-Machina-mäßig. Ich finde immer, die Tatsache, dass man ihn überhaupt erwischt hat, zeigt, dass er nicht von einem Supercomputer gesteuert sein kann. weil der Supercomputer hätte ja den Schritt der Anti-Supercomputer-Partfinder in Wissigativ-Team auch schon voraussehen können. Eigentlich kann ja ein perfekter Schachcomputer nie erwischt werden, weil er das auch schon vorausplanen hat. Er ist immer Einzug voraus. Jetzt sind wir in dieser Rick and Morty Double-Cross-Heist-Movie-Folge, dass der Schachcomputer soder so clever wäre, dass er immer ein Force ist. Oder auch an richtigen Stellen einem falsche Züge sagt. Ja, klar. Weil man menschlich spielen sollte. Nee, aber ich habe auch im Westen nichts Neues gesehen. Und da gibt es ja immer so diese Diskussion, Kriegsfilm, Antikriegsfilm. So kann man einen Antikriegsfilm machen, weil Krieg ist halt schon immer recht cool. Actionreich. Explosion, Actionreich und so. Hat eine gewisse Ästhetik, die man raus da rausziehen kann, 1917 zum Beispiel. Ja genau, gibt es da überhaupt einen Antikriegsfilm? Und ich sage, ja, definitiv gibt es Antikriegsfilme, die schlechten Kriegsfilme, die sau langweilig sind, wo du dir denkst, boah, nee, das zieht sich. Also ich habe schon Filme gesehen, wo ich mir dachte, nee, das sieht sau langweilig aus. Also ich würde sagen, Antikriegsfilme sind vor allem die Filme, die einfach schlecht sind. Wenn du wirklich Krieg verhindern willst, wenn du jetzt zwei Parteien hast und du sagst, da droht Krieg, gebt denen die zehn schlecht bewertetsten Kriegsfilme von IMDB und sagt, die müsst ihr euch angucken. Und danach singen die, boah nee, das sieht so fucking erbärmlich aus. Zehn Stunden französischer Arthouse-Film über den Ersten Weltkrieg. Und man nachdenkt danach so, nee, ich mach was Neustiges. Ja, also wirklich so, jeder hatte schon Filme gesehen, wo er sich dachte, das ... Weil eigentlich die Idee des Films ist ja, dass egal, was man da zeigt, ist cool. Nach einem Hackerfilm, nach einem guten Hackerfilm willst du Hacker werden. Nach einem guten Kochfilm willst du Koch werden. Nach einem guten Kriegsfilm, nee. So, aber nach einem schlechten Kochfilm willst du alles, nur kein Koch werden. Nach einem schlechten Hackerfilm willst du auf gar keinen Fall Hacker werden. Und jetzt denk mal weiter.
Aber auch hier, glaube ich, haben wir so ein Hufeisen-Diagramm, weil ich glaube, je besser der Kriegsfilm gemacht ist, desto besser zeigt er einem in einer guten Story die Schrecken des Krieges. Und wenn nämlich die Charaktere cool sind, man mit denen mitgeht und mitleidet und den Verlust bemerkt und sowas, dann kann ein guter Kriegsfilm noch mehr leisten als ein schlechter Kriegsfilm, wo man sich so langweilt, dass man denkt, I don't want a business with war. Ich glaub, ich glaub doch, ich glaub, ein guter, guter Kriegsfilm kriegt das hin. Aber ja, ich finde das eine sehr spannende Überlegung. Einfach die schlechtesten Filme, danach hast du keinen Bock drauf. Das stimmt, da muss man keinen guten Kriegsfilm machen, wo man Gefahr läuft, Krieg zu verherrlichen. Nee, aber das macht der Film, finde ich, gut, dass man danach keinen Bock auf Krieg hat. Das kommt auch gerade zum richtigen Zeitpunkt. Ich war positiv überrascht und hab den gern geschaut. Dachte trotzdem, kam man trotzdem auf diese Aufrüstungsidee. Lass uns doch alle massiv aufrüsten in Paddel. Aber keine Dächer, nie Dächer. Irgendwie, also ich hab keine Ahnung von Geschichte und so. Und ich schau jetzt Filme auch nicht mit so einem Oh, ist das historisch akkurat oder nicht Brille. Aber manchmal denke ich mir, warum hat niemand Dächer? Dächer? Also zum Beispiel, du schaust einen Ritterfilm und du siehst Innenhof dann auf den Wellen, warum haben die nicht einfach ein Dach drüber? Weil ich meine, klar, es regnet jetzt gerade nicht, aber es muss doch irgendwann regnen. Und dann stehen die da auf dem Burgwall konstant im Regen und keiner sagt, Freunde, können wir vielleicht ein Dach zu bauen?
Zumindest ein Zelt. Irgendwas.
Pavillon. Irgendwas. Und auch da, Erster Weltkrieg
schützengräben. Warum hatten die denn kein Dach?
Also warum, also
du meinst die Schlacht im Heimsklamm?
Ich war in der da und hab da Blechdächer gefunden
im Wald, egal, möchte jetzt gar nicht so ins Detail
gehen, dass ich es hier besser weiß, aber ich denke
mir immer so, historisch akkurat,
warum
haben die alle keine fucking
Vielen Dank. bald, egal, möchte jetzt gar nicht so ins Detail gehen, dass ich es hier besser weiß, aber ich denke mir immer so, historisch akkurat, warum haben die alle keine fucking Dächer? Nichts hat Dächer, ich kann verstehen, warum, damit man, das ist wahrscheinlich schwierig mit den Scheinwerfern und so und dann sieht man den Himmel nicht mehr und der Himmel ist herrlich und du willst immer den Himmel zeigen, Regel Nummer eins beim Film machen, aber trotzdem denke ich mir manchmal, was passiert, wenn es jetzt anfängt zu regnen? Müssen die dann alle nach Hause gehen einfach? Stehen die alle einfach im Regen? Gibt es Umstände, wo man sagt, bei so einem Sturm lassen wir es jetzt mal sein? Ja. Und da gibt es die eine Szene, wo der diese Granate in den anderen Kützengraben reinwirft und ich denke mir, mach ein Dach drauf. Also das ist jetzt nicht die abwägendste Idee, da was reinzuwerfen, wie wär's mit nem Brettholz drüber. So, ich will euch den Film nicht kaputt machen jetzt, egal, der Film ist toll, schau euch den an. Denkt nicht, die ganze Zeit wäre es nicht viel besser, wenn die einfach ein fucking Dach drauf, also es ist ja wirklich, wenn du ein Loch graben kannst, dann kannst du einfach ein Dach drauf bauen, genau wie, stell dir vor, wie fucking aufwendig ist es, eine Ritterburg zu bauen. Und dann bau doch einfach ein Dach über alles. Über die gesamte Burg. Alles. Über den Innenhof, über die Welle. Einfach ein Dach. Das ist doch kein Stress. Und dann sind die trocken. Haben Sie in Ihrer Partei noch andere Punkte, für die Sie einstehen? Ja, wir haben schon noch ein Rentenprogramm. Weil ich habe ja jetzt eigentlich nach dem Rentenprogramm gefragt. Und Sie kommen wieder mit Ihrer Dachgeschichte. Und die Wählerinnen und Wähler wollen von Ihnen wissen, was noch andere Punkte sind. Ich meine, Sie sind die Dachpartei. Wir dachten, das heißt Deutschland, Österreich und Schweiz. Wir sind der Dachverband von der Dachpartei. Und wir sagen, warum nicht einfach ein Dach? Die meisten Probleme sind ... Okay, Sie fangen wieder damit an. Ja. Genau jetzt nach dem Rennprogramm. Freiluft Festival. Warum macht man nicht einfach ein Dach drüber?
Selbst das...
Das haben die Leute nämlich vergessen.
Wussten Sie nämlich...
Entschuldigung, jetzt möchte ich auch mal eine Frage stellen.
Aber jetzt fängt es an zu regnen.
Aha, so, ja.
Gut, es ist ein Open-Air-Wahlprogramm.
Nein!
Wussten Sie nämlich, dass das Kolosseum auch ein Dach hatte?
Habe ich in Gladiator nicht gesehen.
Warum nicht? Zeigen Sie doch das schöne Dach.
Wenn es nämlich anfängt zu regnen, dann werden die Löwen nass.
Woher kommt denn Ihre Fokussierung auf Dächer?
Ich verstehe nur nicht, warum die Leute in historischen Filmen einfach immer die Dächer weglassen.
Warum hassen Sie Regen so sehr?
Ist doch auch immer schön, in so einem Sommerregen zu stehen.
Ja, zwei Minuten lang, bevor sie wieder unter ein Dach geht. Wissen Sie, wie ich meine Frau kennengelernt habe? Im Regen, draußen, an der Seine. Wie an der Seine. An der Seine in Paris, beim Regen, war romantisch. Wäre da ein Dach drüber. A la pluie? A la pluie. Es hat an der Seine geregnet. Jetzt interessiert mich doch. Ja genau, da war kein Dach. Und deswegen haben meine Frau und ich uns kennengelernt. Geküsst und das war der Moment, wo wir uns einander verliebt haben. Jetzt haben wir drei wunderschöne Kinder. Kann ich da aber Bilder sehen, Entschuldigung. Ja, hier einen Moment, da muss ich kurz entsperren. Ach, geht das nicht wegen der Maske. So, hier. Schauen Sie mal. Das sind die Bilder. Und da möchte ich mal sagen, Sie mit Ihren Dächern hätten diesen Moment wahrscheinlich zerstört. Sie wollen alles überdachen. Aber Sie kennen das Sprichwort. Sie wollen die Sand überdachen. Sie kennen das Sprichwort, dass Kinder für die Eltern immer schöner aussehen als für andere. Wieso, das ist doch ein süsses Kind. Schauen Sie, das ist ja evolutionär ganz sinnvoll, dass Sie als Elternteil das Kind schön finden, aber jetzt kommen Sie auch noch mit einer Evolutionstheorie.
Dächer und Eugenik. Prio drei.
Das ist ein anderes Thema. Die Eidechsen
müssen weg.
Was war das gerade?
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Prospekt. Aber das sage ich jetzt nur,
das ist ja nicht objektiv, wenn Sie sagen, unsere
wunderschönen Kinder, für Sie subjektiv.
Weil das Kind sieht aus wie ein Frosch. Entschuldigung,
aber es sieht aus wie ein Frosch. Ja, ich sehe es. Ich sehe es ein bisschen. Ja, oder? Süßer Frosch. Krötig. Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass Sie sich ein bisschen verrannt haben mit Ihrem Dachthema. Ich würde noch gerne einmal einen Film sehen, so ein Historiendrama, wo einfach mal jemand sagt. Reden Sie noch mit rauerer Stimmen. Noch rauer.
Wo jemand einfach mal sagt, warum nicht einfach mal ein Dach.
Rauer, noch rauer.
Wissen Sie, ich habe mit meiner Tech-Firma mehrere Millionen Dollar gemacht.
Und alle sagen, ich sollte das den armen Leuten spenden, aber ich sage nein.
Ich werde damit einen Film drehen, ein Historiendrama mit so fucking
viel Dächern, dass man
keinen Lichtstrahl mehr sieht.
Es gibt keine Outdoor-Selder.
Nichts, nichts.
Jeder ist knochendrocken. Einmal gibt es eine Szene,
wo einen fragt, mit mal, regnet es gerade, weil man hört zu.
Aber sind wir nicht überdacht,
weil wir das Himmelszelt haben?
Vielen Dank.
Ich bin noch den ganzen Abend hier. Gegen dieses Argument haben wir nichts. Das war ein Argument, vor dem wir Angst haben. Oder zum Beispiel so ein Wikinger-Schiff oder so. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da mitgehen kann. So ein Wikinger-Schiff. Das hat ein Dach. Nein, im Film hat es nie Dach. Auf dem Schiff Deck. Aber die sind ja auf dem Deck. So ein klassisches Wikinger-Langschiff hat keinen Unterdeck. Natürlichiff hat keinen Unterdeck. Die hängen da drauf. Die hängen ja nicht drauf.
Doch, und dann anfängt es zu regnen, sagen die, oh, na, nasser Wikinger. Das ist ein starker Kaffee, nasser Wikinger, kannst du auch sagen. Bei Northman hat es mich aufgeregt. Northman die ganze Zeit, und es ist ja schon in gewisser Weise klar übertrieben, überzeichnet, aber war schon irgendwie, wirkte für mich wie ein historisch korrekter, cooler Einblick in die Wikingerzeit.
Und da immer am Regnen, alle schlecht gelaunt, die ganze Zeit schlecht gelaunt, gut, passiert auch eine Menge Unsinn, eine Menge blöde Sachen, aber alle sind schlecht gelaunt und grummeln dann immer in ihren Bart, bei diesem Riesenregen, überall Sturm, das ist nie immer schön. Ich will mal einen Wikinger mit Sonnenbrand sehen. Ja, stimmt. Der sagt, oh, heidertaus, jetzt war ja wieder zu lange in der Sonne. Heidertaus, Sonnenbrennt. Ich glaube, aber daran denkt man auch nicht. Man denkt immer, oh, Zeitreise ins Mittelalter, in Juhu, dann erkläre ich denen mal, wie Strom funktioniert. Dann pack dir mal die 50 Sonnencreme mit Fliegel-Sakten.
Die sind alle scheiße drauf.
Und du kommst an, so Leute, wer hat
Bock auf Geometrie?
Also, Satz des Pythagoras und die nur so,
ne, alles schlecht,
die Pest den ganzen Tag.
Meine Finger fallen mir ab und ich habe Sonnenbrand.
Alles ist, mein Körper
verschimmelt, während ich lebe, ich bin fast tot,
meine Tochter ist vom Greifen weggenommen worden und der dunkle Schatten im Wald hat alle meine Söhne umgebracht. Und du so, ja okay, cool, aber ich, guck mal, ein Feuerzeug, guck mal, cool, halt mich auch nicht vor meinen nur 80 Krankheiten, die ich habe. Die Prioritäten sind andere, die Probleme sind größer, ich glaube, Mittelalter war eine richtig, richtig, richtige Scheisszeit.
Also recht, aber jetzt mal ganz
herrlich. Ja? Ja.
Eine richtige Scheisszeit, glaube ich.
Wo würdest du, du würdest ja zu den Dinosauriern
reisen, nehme ich mal an, oder? Also wenn
die Zeitreise bestehen würde, würdest du zu den Dinosauriern,
oder würdest du sagen, na, lass mal,
lass uns mal lieber
Jurassic Park. Lass mal nach vorne gucken,
würde ich sagen. Aber würdest du lieber in die Zukunft reisen? Ja. Okay, in welches Jahr? Nahe Zukunft. Nahe Zukunft, nächste Mittwoch. Nee, aber so Februar, 2023. Februar, okay. Wie siehst du aus? Wissen wir nicht, weißt du auch nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie aussieht. Aber das würde dir helfen. Dann sagst du, ich komme aus der Zukunft, aus der Vergangenheit. Alle what? What? Im Jahre 2022. Ich bin vier Monate. Wie ist die WM ausgegangen? Wir haben verloren. Ach, fuck. Zum Glück habe ich es mir nicht angeguckt. Nee, aber ich weiß nicht, wie es im Februar ist, wo wir da stehen. Ob es da fliegende Autos gibt? Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber wissen wir nicht. Ja, das kann schon sein. Stell dir mal vor, du gehst drei Monate in die Zukunft und alle haben Jetpacks und riesige Gebäude und denkst dir nur, was zur Hölle ist hier passiert? Was habe ich übersprungen? Was ist passiert? So von einem Tag auf den anderen Zukunft einfach. Du denkst so, scheiße, scheiße, scheiße, ich hätte genau diesen, wo man im YouTube-Video ein bisschen zu weit nach vorne geskript hat, und dann wird zurückgekommen, denkt, wait, wie kommen wir denn jetzt hier hin?
Die ist jetzt eine von den Bösen, what?
Ich hätte nicht vier Folgen überspringen sollen.
Nee, genau. Das kann ja sein.
Jetpacks fliegen durch die Gegend.
Ohne Menschen. Noch.
Kann auch sein. Ja, wahrscheinlich kann man sich dann,
wahrscheinlich liegen überall in der Kölner Innenstadt so Jetpacks rum,
die man sich so mieten kann.
Und die sind so egal geworden,
dass man die einfach überall hinwirft
und sich die dann so vom Boden nehmen kann und so
Ja.
Letzten Endes... Und dann bricht man nämlich damit das Schlüsselbein.
Ja, wie einfach.
Technologischer Fortschritt ist einfach innerhalb kürzester Zeit wieder trivial.
Als diese Elektroroller kamen, dachten alle, what the fuck, das ist die Zukunft.
Innerhalb von zwei Tagen, die stehen nur am Weg rum.
Genauso wird es mit den Jetpacks und fliegenden Autos auch sein.
Ein Physiotherapeut im Krankenhaus, der kam dann irgendwann, ich wurde operiert, am nächsten Morgen kam dann irgendwann der Physiotherapeut. Stefan hatte sich Schlüsselbein gebrochen, weil er mit dem E-Scooter hingefallen ist und er ist gerade wieder auf Regenerationskurs. Vielen Dank für diese kleine, sehr sympathische, gut gelahmte Zusammenfassung. Irgendjemand muss es ja machen. Und dann kam der und hat erstmal gesagt, ich habe gesagt, wie das passiert, hat er gefragt, ich habe gesagt, E-Roller hingefallen, hat er gesagt, ja, kein Mitleid. Also wir sind nicht so smooth ins Gespräch gestiegen. Verstehe. Und dann hat er diese Theorie aufgestellt, dass die mehr CO2-Emissionen in die Welt ballern als Autos. Gut, aber das ist jetzt gar nicht der Grund, warum du ins Krankenhaus gekommen bist. Also das war jetzt gar nicht die Art von... So, und dann war ich jetzt in der Diskussion mit ihm, warum diese Roller eh scheiße sind, weil die erstens, Zitat, die landen doch alle im Rhein. So, rein damit. Rheinfall? Ja. Hatten wir auch schon mal das Thema. Ich würde mal ein großes Fragezeichen machen, diese Aussage, die landen ja alle im Rhein, erstens. Zweitens hat er gesagt, ja und abends kommt dann so ein Bulli mit so einem Dieselmotor an, sammelt die alle ein, tankt die auf und fährt die wieder los, fährt die wieder rum. Und das war seine Argumentation dafür, dass jede Fahrt, die wir quasi sparen mit dem Auto, wieder reingeholt wird, weil dann nachts diese ominöse Diesel-Lokomotive ankommt.
Diese, was soll das denn für ein Gefährt sein, was so viel, weil, überleg mal, der sammelt dann nachts, keine Ahnung, 30 Roller ein, bringt die wieder, lädt die auf, bringt die wieder weg. Und schmerzt ihn rein. Okay, diesen Aspekt lassen wir mal weg, wir sind ja schon bei zwei. So, und der fährt eine Fahrt nachts, und aber im Laufe des Tages sparen wir ja
so, so viele Autofahrten
mit, indem Leute lieber
mit dem Roller fahren, mal eben.
Und ich denke mir, wie kannst du das
im Verhältnis setzen zu dieser
was ist das denn für ein ominöses
Dieselfahrzeug nachts?
Ich stelle mir jetzt wirklich so eine Dampfwalze vor,
die einfach mit so einer riesen Schmauchfahrt.
Und dann fährt die durch die Kölner Innenstadt.
Mit so Riesenarmen, die auch jeweils drei Dieselmotoren haben.
So Bergarbeiter, die so eine Lampe auf der Stirn haben und so Russ verschmiert und dann die Sachen einsammeln.
Durch die Städte ziehen und diese Roller austauschen.
Und dann, genau, und dann
morgens hat sich so dann der Dampf gelegt
und legt sich so auf den Asphalt
und der Physiotherapeut läuft zur Arbeit.
Kein Mitleid. Kein Mitleid.
Was für eine geile Antwort das ist.
Ja, ich habe mir Schlüssel mehr gebraucht
und wenn ich es gerade anfange, kein Mitleid.
Habe ich auch nicht auf den Verlangen. Genau,
ich bin jetzt auch nicht wegen Mitleid unbedingt gekommen,
aber... Naja, das war der Physiotherapeut im Krankenhaus und fand ich so ein bisschen schwierig, da war ich in so einer Situation, wo ich mich auseinandergesetzt gefühlt habe, irgendwie mit dem diskutieren zu müssen. Das ist noch mal eine Dystopie, oder? Dass Ärzte dich nur dann behandeln, wenn sie finden, dass das eine gerechtfertigte Verletzung ist. Das ist aber ein bisschen so. Ich glaube, wenn du nach der Soffnung reinkommst, weil du einfach zu viel getrunken hast und in so einem Koma-tösem Zustand bist, dann kriegst du schon einfach nicht die geilste, netteste Behandlung. Ich glaube, die sind dann schon eher genervt, weil die Leute Betten wegnehmen, die es eigentlich nötig haben. Okay. Moment, du prangerst hier, das sind aber ganz schön harte Vorwürfe hier. Ist das wieder ein Hot-Take? Nein, ist nicht so hart. Nee, okay. Du konntestellisieren, ich bin nicht so tief drin in allem, dass ich jetzt verstehe, wie hart der Vorwurf. Ich bin nicht so clever. Das heißt aber, du sagst quasi, dass Ärzte sich hier diesen hypokratischen Eid nicht so zu Herzen nehmen. Der heißt, behandle jeden, egal ob Maria Theresa
oder irgend so ein Vollidiot, der besoffen
gegen Baum gefahren ist. Und jeden Tag
eine gute Tat. Ja.
Vorsicht vor Äpfeln.
Wenn jemand Äpfel isst,
Abstand.
Fucking Abstand, okay?
Wir wollen mit Äpfeln nichts zu...
Was hatte Hippokrates gegen Äpfel eigentlich?
Was Kloblauch für Vampire isst, sind Äpfeln nichts zu... Was hatte Hippokrates gegen Äpfel eigentlich? Was Knoblauch für Vampire ist und Äpfel für Erz. Ach ja, das ist schwierig. Kein Mitleid. Arschloch. Aber ohne Scheiß, es sieht so cool aus, diese Narbe, die ich jetzt habe. Ja, ich habe sie kurz gesehen, als du hier reingedockt bist. Sieht aus wie ein Haifischbiss. Ja. Aber ich werde, ich werde eine grosse Geschichte erfinden, weil ich kann ja nicht allen sagen, dies guter Unfall, verunglückt. Dann sagen nämlich alle kein Mitleid. Aber wenn das ein Haifischbiss ist, müsste der Hai ja deinen gesamten Kopf im Maul haben und dann in die Schulter. Es ist genau so kieferförmig Schulter. Ja, aber da wäre doch da, wo dein Kopf ist, wäre doch dann der Kiefer das Heist. Der müsste deinen kompletten Kopf zerbissen haben. Nee, es wäre genau wie angeknabbert. Stell dir einen Keks vor und dann kommt oben so ein Hai, beißt so eine Kante ab. So ein Jaffer-Cake, wenn du oben nur die Schokolade abknabbelst. Das habe ich ja jetzt gerade hier oben an der Schulter oben links. Und das stelle ich mir vor. Und dann finde ich so eine Geschichte, wie ich so eine Frau gerettet habe, die ins Wasser gefallen ist. Und warum hast du dann nur auf der einen Seite die Narben und nicht auf der anderen, wenn der Hai von beiden Seiten gebissen hat? Weil unten noch die Frau. Er hatte die unten im Mund. Genau, er, meine Seelenverwandte hat genau die gleichen Verletzungen, aber nur am Rücken. Verstehst du? Moment, also, ach so.
Also sie war mit ihrem Bauch an deinem Rücken, so seid ihr geschwommen.
Wir wollten doch jetzt auch eigentlich wieder über deine Dachpartei reden.
Ja.
Ich verstehe jetzt gar nicht, warum du mich jetzt so löcherst.
Und der hat dann quasi wie so ein belegtes Brötchen, Menschenbrötchen, in euch beide reingebissen?
Genau.
Okay, ja, ist ja romantisch.
Wie so ein Menschenburger.
Und seid ihr dann auch zusammengekommen? Mann, Poolnudel, Frau. Verstehe, verstehe. Pasta. Menschenpasta-Snack. Pasta-Sandwich, ja. Aber seid ihr dann auch irgendwie euch nähergekommen, oder war es das dann für euch? Nee, das war es, das war es. Das war es? Also ihr habt dann nicht noch ein zweites date mein erstes date meine beide von einem hei gebissen und es gab kein zweites mehr pass auf weil ich war absolut in panik habe ich sie dem heiz und fras vorgeworfen oh ja und das fand sie dann eine unmännliche aktion ja ich verstehe und hat dann abstand von mir genommen weil mein erster dann ist auch einfach sie, würde ja jeder sagen, würde ja jeder doch sagen, einfach Überlebensinstinkt.
Dann habe ich die Frau in das Maul des Hais gestoppt, damit ich nicht gefressen werde. Und dann kam der Biss auf beiden. Das ist die Geschichte, die ich erfinde, weil Rollerscooter mir zu uncool ist, sage ich allen, ich habe eine Frau in das Maul des Hais gestopft, um selber nicht gefressen zu werden. Damit sie den Biss abfedert, damit du nur von einer Kieferhälfte getroffen hast. Genau. Okay. Rückflug war peinlich. Ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Auch das Rückschwimmen zurück ans Ufer. Warum hat der Haier da warum hat der Haider nicht weitergemacht, konnte der dann in die Flucht geschlagen werden, oder wie?
Ja, weil sie hat es dann noch geschafft, geistengegenwärtig wie sie war, so mit beiden Händen so außen auf die Augen zu hauen.
Ah, okay. Und dann hat er sich mit der Puhnudel zurückgezogen, hat er die Puhnudel noch schnell rausgesaugt.
Ja, die Puhnudel hat er noch reingesaugt, wie so eine Penne. Und dann ist er gegangen. Gegangen. Oder wie Haie das macht. Dann ist er gegangen. Haie sind ja Säugetiere, die gehen. Im Grunde gehen die mit ihren Flossen. Die können ja quasi auch auf dem Strand, könnten die ja genauso auch mit ihren Flossen gehen. Das ist ja für die kein Unterschied. Es ist halt langsamer. Es ist ein Stück
langsamer, ja, das stimmt.
Nee, das ist die Geschichte.
Okay, aha.
Vielleicht mögen Haie ja gar
keine Menschen, nur halt Surfbretter.
Halt so, das ist, der Mensch
ist so Beiwerk, das ist so, wenn du
so dir ein Brötchen kaufst und denkst, warum ist da
Salat drauf, wir machen wie was vor.
So ist der Mensch für den Hai, das ist so,
ja gut, wird halt mitgegessen, muss
sein, will ich aber eigentlich gar nicht. Vielleicht ist der
Vielen Dank. wenn du so dir ein Brötchen kaufst und denkst, warum ist da Salat drauf, wir machen wie was vor, so ist der Mensch für den Hai, das ist so, ja gut, wird halt mitgegessen, muss sein, will ich aber eigentlich gar nicht, vielleicht ist der Mensch nur die Beilage, aber kann der Mensch das wahrhaben, dass der Mensch nur die Beilage ist, nein, der Mensch sagt, der Hai will den Menschen fressen, Gottkomplex, der Mensch kann sich selber nicht als Salatblatt der Evolution sehen. Nein, nein, wir sind das Steak, das feinquilierte Kobel-Rind-Steak auf dem Menü des Heis, des Haifisches. Das sind wir nämlich. Ja. Und nicht weniger! Ich habe eine Serie geguckt, sehr zu empfehlen, Cunk on Earth, die neue Serie von der BBC, ganz tolle Serie, so ein bisschen in der Geschichte vielleicht so von An Idiot Abroad oder der Ali-G-Show, wo sie in einer Rolle mit Experten redet über verschiedene Themen und sie stellt halt die allerdümmsten Fragen der Welt, aber es ist alles sehr cool produziert und glaube ich, das kann man auch mal, ich glaube, das würde vielen, ich glaube, das ist eine schöne Sache. Dann möchte ich gerne empfehlen The White Lotus. Habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal empfohlen. Ist nämlich jetzt die zweite Staffel rausgekommen. Dadurch habe ich sie gesehen. Die zweite Staffel? Ist jetzt rausgekommen, ist jetzt auf HBO. Nee! Ich habe noch nicht Angst. Alter! Ich höre hier auf, fuck it. Ich schaue mir das jetzt. Alter, wirklich? Ich dachte, boah, es war so, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, wir beruhigen uns, wir beruhigen uns, wow, das war so ein Gemütssprung von, ach, jetzt stellt ihr wieder seine ewig alte Serie vor, die wir alle schon gesehen haben zu, was, es gibt eine neue Staffel? Weiter, mach weiter. Es gibt die zweite Staffel Yes!
Es spielt wieder in einem White Lotus-Ressort,
diesmal glaube ich auf Sizilien.
Oh Mann!
Oh, warum
machen die Achterbahn?
Ey, wann lernen es
fucking Serienproduzenten endlich, dass
sich niemand für Sizilien
interessiert? Game of Thrones Staffel, Sizilien, sonniges Palermo, Sonnengreife, Erdoman. Rogue One, ich bin auch Sizilien. Das war alles Sizilien. Obi-Wan. Ja, Obi-Wan, die letzte Staffel Lost. Man lernt die das endlich mal, niemand interessiert sich für Sizilien. Florentin. Der Vesuv ist aus, erzählt, Freunde, lernt's endlich. Meine Narbe schmerzt, meine Narbe schmerzt. Heißt das ein Hai ist in der Nähe? Ja, ja. Du weißt schon, wer. Die leuchtet blau. Du weißt schon, wer ist in der Nähe, kleiner Hai. Aber er fängt richtig gut. Also, kann man die sich schon anglotzen? Kann man die sich schon reinglotzen? Es gibt gerade die erste Folge, ich glaube, es wird jetzt wieder so wöchentlich veröffentlicht, was mich ja auch näher, da bin ich ja kein Fan von, aber immerhin haben wir eine und zweite Staffel. Ich finde sie zien toll, ich verstehe die Achterbahnfahrt, der Gefühle gerade nicht. Große Emotionen bei Florentin, große Emotionen. Er liebt die zweite Staffel, er hasst Sizilien. Ich war halt selber schon vor Ort und ich sehe halt alle Ungereimtheiten. Ich sehe jedes Dach, das fehlt, weil ich war in Sizilien und ich habe die Dächer gesehen. Gibt es Haie bei Sizilien? Ja, es gibt auch überdachte Haie, auch da alle Pools sind überdacht,
immer diese herrlichen Terrassen,
die sind alle überdacht, in Serien
nie, warum?
Also folgt dem Twitter-Kanal,
ich weiß nicht genau, wie er heisst,
Podcast Ufo empfiehlt, glaube ich.
Empfehlungen, glaube ich, ja, da könnt ihr noch mal
alles nachlesen, CUNK
CUNK, ja, jeder weiß,
wie man CUNK schreibt. Ja, K-U-N-N-N-N-K. Arschloch. Das klingt versaut, ne? Kunk. Es ist so... Komisch. Obwohl es ein... Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, warum das versaut klingt. Obwohl es ein Fantasiewort ist. Ja, okay, dann mach mal ein deutsches Fantasiewort, das schmutzig klingt. Schlotze. Ja, Potze. Schlöse. Dumme Pinöse. Titze. Naja. Ja, schickt uns ... Stimmt, im Grunde bist du so ein bisschen die deutsche Philomena Kank, die auch einen versauten Nachnamen hast. Ja, aber auch nicht so sehr, dass es jetzt, dass man jetzt das Programm irgendwie als Porno oder sowas ... Nee, aber du bist schon sexy, also du bist schon ... Ja, das war ja klar. Du hast eine gewisse erotische Ausstrahlung, das kann man schon sagen. Schickt uns neue Intros. Unabhängig jetzt von Carolinas wunderschönen Gedicht. Das ist deine Verführungskunst. Möchte ich gerne, dass ihr uns wieder neue tolle Intros schickt. Bitte kurz. I can't do this all on my own, no, I know, I'm no Superman. Ende. Für mich sogar. Das ist das Intro. I can do it all on my ... Da könnte es für mich auch vorbei sein. Yes, no, maybe, I don't know. Reicht ja. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Passt, man hat es verstanden. Da will ich es harmonisch schon wollen, dass es sich auflöst. Aber you get the idea. Ich fände cooles, knackiges Intro, schön, tut euch aus, das kann es ja noch nicht gewesen sein. Nee, auf keinen Fall, nee, nee, nee. Weil wir haben mal geguckt, wie viele Hörer wir haben, Hörerinnen. Haben wir eigentlich schon länger? Und wir haben etwa 0,5 Prozent von euch haben Intros geschickt. Und das kann es ja wohl nicht sein. Haben wir eigentlich schon länger Hörerintros als ...
Intro?
Oh, sag ich, Folge 123 war die erste Folge mit Hörerintro.
Wir haben schon länger Hörerintros als unser Copyright-geclaimtes, illegales Intro von Michael Giacchino.
Wahnsinn, was für eine Reise es war, ne, Stefan?
Ja, was für eine teure, anwaltslastige Rechtsstreitphase das doch war.
Aus Wahnsinn, was für eine Reise es war, ne, Stefan? Ja, was für eine teure, anwaltslastige Rechtsstreitphase das doch war.
Aus vielen Gründen.
Rückblickend hätte man es einfach durchziehen können.
Ich glaube, die meisten Sachen sind gar kein Problem.
Es ist tatsächlich ... Wo kein Kläger, da kein Richter.
Es ist tatsächlich ...
Ich kenne ja mehrere mediale Ausspielwege.
Und ich sag mal, es gibt ...
Nimm mir zwei.
Fuck.
Podcasts. Ähm... Nee, ist egal. YouTube. Und auf YouTube ist ja dieses Copywriting brutal, einfach so. Da wird ja alles weg Copyright. Deswegen nennt man YouTube ja deswegen die Copyright-Schlotze. Die Jotine. Okay. Nee, nee. und dann kannst du ja bei deinem Video, du siehst da wirklich so ein Video, und dann siehst du mit so roten Flecken, wie so, als hätte das Pocken oder so, als wäre das Video krank, hat das so ganz viele rote Punkte. So, und da ist überall Copyright-Claims. Das ist Wahnsinn. Bei den Podcasts hingegen interessiert sich niemand dafür. Niemand. Niemand. Wir können jetzt hier Wild Wild West einspielen. Das ist The Wild Wild West. The Wild Wild West is so fucking super wild. Genau. Und da eigentlich noch an YouTube hätten wir jetzt schon eine Urheberrechtsklage am Hals. In Podcast Mania, würde ich mal sagen, wir befinden uns ja aktuell in Podcast Mania. So weit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen, aber es ist schon der Wild West. Doch, es ist schon Podcast Mania. Nee, nee, nee. Stefan, hör auf jetzt. Hör mal auf, du wirst so rot direkt. Nee, ja, ja. Bist du allergisch gegen irgendwas? Das Wort Mania, glaube ich. Wirklich, das hilft jetzt nicht. Du hast schon recht, wir können machen, was wir wollen. Mal gucken, wie lange das noch der Fall ist. Solange müsst ihr uns Intros schicken. Schickt uns eure Spotify-Intros. Ja. Ich hätte schon Bock, richtig geile Intros zu bekommen von euch. Bin ich ganz ehrlich. Wisst ihr, was ich auf euch Bock hätte? Ein geiles Intro. Von euch. Von euch da draußen. Schickt uns das und zwar an ... Was ist der beste Weg? Das fragen nämlich viele ... Was fragen viele ... Zentrale at podcast-ufo.fail. Ja, aber da hast du doch das Problem, dass das Sprecherraum voll ist oder sowas.
Ja, das stimmt. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich habe das Passwort vergessen. Ich habe aber noch einen Laptop, mein alter Laptop. Der ist noch eingeloggt. Und sollte der eines Tages aus irgendeinem Grund auch immer sich ausloggen, dann war es das. Dann machen wir eine Hypnose. Weil das habe ich ja nicht mal gehört, irgendwie so ein Bitcoin-Millionär hat das Passwort vergessen für seinen Bitcoin-Wallet und hat er sich, hat er noch einen Versuch gehabt und hat er sich hypnotisieren lassen, um auf das Passwort zu kommen. Wie viel fucking Vertrauen brauchst du zu dem Hypnotiseur? Weil wenn er sein Passwort ja unter Hypnose sagt,
ist er davon abhängig, dass der Hypnotiseur ihm danach das Passwort sagt.
Ja.
Aber der könnte ja auch einfach sagen, nee, kam nix.
Da kam nur die ganze Zeit ihre tiefsten ... dann abhängig, dass der Hypnotiseur ihm danach das Passwort sagt.
Da kamen nur die ganze Zeit ihre tiefsten perversen Fetische,
haben sie immer und immer im kleinsten, penibelsten Detail mir aufgezählt.
Aber kein Passwort.
Wiedersehen, machen Sie die Tür zu auf dem Weg nach außen, bitte.
Und dann war der auch noch teurer als das Geld, was auf dem Wallet ist.
Und dann hast du das Passwort.
Wallet.
Wallet ist, ich glaube, ich habe ja jede Woche ein neues Lieblingswort in Englisch und mein aktuelles Lieblingswort ist Wolt.
Wolt.
Wie Tresor.
Ich glaube, es ist wegen Ocean's Eleven, weil da Terry Bennett ständig How did they get in my vault?
They made a copy of my vault.
How did
There are people in my vault.
Ständig immer dieses
What's the situation in the vault?
Oh, they must have
been a fake vault.
Ich liebe diesen Teil des Films.
Ich schaue mir den sehr oft an, weil immer so Oh mein Gott, es ist ein schönes Wort, weil man kann da so viel reinstecken, und es klingt irgendwie sophisticated, weil es ja noch diesen französischen Schreibweisen Aspekt hat. Das klingt so, als wären zu viele Buchstaben auf zu engem Raum. So Wort, Wort, Wort. Und es will so raus.
Und man kommt damit auch gut.
Ja genau, man kommt nicht.
Ja, das ist so als.
Fordernd.
Eigentlich, ich glaube, eigentlich müsste man das Wort trennen können, aber man kann es nicht trennen. Wort, Wort, Wort. Wört. Das ist ein gutes Wort, richtig starkes Wort. Podcast-Ufer-Empfehlung, das Wort, Wort. Das Wort, Wort. Weil das kann man auch so gut wütend sagen, weil manche Dinge kannst du, verdammt nochmal, sie haben meine Petunien kaputt gemacht.
Das klingt nicht cool. Gänseblümchen kann man auch. Sie haben meine Gänse. Moment mal, das sind meine Gänseblümchen. Das klingt nicht gut. Wohingegen, they're in my Volt. Das klingt einfach super. Wie Voldemort. Ja, Volt. Es ist genau, also da muss man ja sagen, Vold, Voldemort ist super, weil Mord ist ja eh tot und Vold hat so dieses Vold, ja wie Volt. Wobei ich finde, Volt ist auch ein fucking gutes Wort, tausend Volt. Eigenname, Thomas Volt. Ja, aber wie ist es der perfekte Mensch, um das zu erfinden? Weil es klingt elektrisch so, Volt. Das ist so Volt. War er streng befeindet mit der Firma Watt. Watt? Dann kam Herr Ampere und hat gesagt, so, wir klären das jetzt in Ruhe. Und dann kam Herr Ohm und hat gesagt, was ist denn hier los? Dann kam Dezibel und hat gesagt, Ohm ist jetzt Dezibel. Hat Ohm gesagt, ja, aber ich bin doch viermal Widerstand. Habt ihr schon was für Arbeit? Kann ich mal reinwarten? Aber vor allem das Problem ist, du könntest keine Serie über Physiker machen, weil die sich ja Instant spoilern, wer die guten Physiker sind und welche nicht. Du hast jetzt irgendwie Ronald Beckenschneider und Walter Röntgen und man denkt sich, ja, wer von den beiden wird wahrscheinlich am Ende der erfolgreichere Physiker sein? Ich hätte so Bock auf so eine Abraham Lincoln Vampire Hunter. Diaries? Wie heißt die Vampire? Ja, interessante. Ich meine, du bist professioneller Serienautor, ich bin da nicht in der Lage, das zu kritizieren. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange man nichts schreiben kann, bis es professionell verfliegt. Abraham Lincoln Vampire Diaries. Also Abraham Lincoln ist selber Vampir oder Jagdvampir? Vampirjäger. Okay. So alternate history Fantasy. Und ich finde das ja geil, das mal mit so den Röntgens zu machen. So und dem Tesla. Und ich finde ja geil diesen Stromkrieg zwischen Tesla und Edison zu erzählen. Gleichstrom gegen Wechselstrom. Aber dass es wirklich ein Stromkrieg ist zwischen diesen beiden. So ein bisschen wie bei Prestige. Oh ja. Aber ich glaube, so eine Art Film gibt es aber. Tesla hat dann so einen Coil. Tesla hat auch so einen Tesla-Gun. Ja, so einen so einen Toilgun. Und irgendwann haben die so Marvel-esk Superhelden völlig überhöht, aber das, weil das ja auch geil ist, nach Corona zu sagen, Wissenschaftler sind die neuen Superhelden. Superhelden at all wear capes und auch unsere. Und dann sind die ganzen, dann machen wir aus den krassen Wissenschaftassen Wissenschaftlern der damaligen Zeit, machen wir so alternate history, krasse Marvel-mässig überhöhte Filme, wo die so Infinity War-mässig ineinander reinrennen. Und Wilhelm Röntgen verschwindet so, und dann sieht man aus seinem Skelett und dann taucht so ein Riesenblitz auf. Röntgen, nein, Wilhelm Röntgen. Dann kommt Werner Heisenberg, niemand versteht, was der macht mit seinem Quantenkram. Die Staffel war weird irgendwie. Quantenkram, zu kompliziert. Und dann dieser Nils-Bohr-Charakter irgendwie immer mit diesem weirden, dass die gleichzeitig existieren. Das wäre so geil. Stell dir mal vor, so Dr. Strange-mäßig. Die sind super positioniert übereinander und beide, also die machen beide gleichzeitig. Schießen die auf Bohr und dann stirbt er, aber daneben ist noch ein anderer Boha. Er scheint dann so ein Drr und dann so ganz viele Boas um einen herum.
Und dann so Miau und dann so Moment mal, wo kommt das her Miau und dann kommt so ein Wissenschaftler mit so Schrödinger mit seiner Katze rein. Ich habe euch bereits erwartet. And now, young Skywalker, you will die. Bei der hat er auch Stromkräfte. Woher hat der Imperator dann die Stromkräfte? Könnte man das nicht einbinden, dass der dadurch ... Das soll kein Crossover sein. Nein, aber weil du ja gesagt hast, Abram Lincoln ist mit dabei. Nein. Aber was hat jetzt dieser Abram Lincoln Vampirjäger-Plot? Also der ist dann einfach B-Plot, oder? Nee, der war nur ein Beispiel Beispiel für mich, muttechnisch, wie das Ganze aussehen soll.
Also der, ach, ich verstehe,
weil Abraham Lincoln die Vampire aus ihrer
Sklaverei befreit, indem er die
Häng dich nicht daran fest, weil das war ein
Beispielbild in meinem
Wort. Die Vampire
sind die Sklaven und Abraham Lincoln
befreit die sozusagen
von ihrem Vampirfluch.
Ich hab den filmlich gesehen.
Und Wilkes Booth ist ja auch dabei. Ich meine, können wir da mal ganz kurz drüber reden. Abraham Lincoln wurde erschossen in einem Theater. In einer privaten Loge. Im Englischen würde man sagen einer Booth. The Killing Booth.
Und er wurde erschossen von einem Mann namens John Wilkes Booth. John, I'm shooting in the face Booth. Das war sein Mittelname. Red Flags. I will shoot Abraham Lincoln in the fucking face Booth. Hat das jemand auf dem Schirm, dass Lincoln in der booth von booth weggeboothed wurde? Lass mich dir sagen, pro Tag passieren so viele Dinge, dass natürlich auch Wunder passieren oder grosse Zufälle. Es ist komplett normal und okay, dass du das jetzt erkennst. Du kannst das nicht drauf schliessen, dass es irgendwie einen Gott gibt, der die Geschicke der Menschheit lenkt. Sondern es passieren so viele Dinge, dass es super unwahrscheinlicher wäre, wenn solche Zufälle und Wunder nicht passieren. Und du meinst wirklich, dass John F. Kennedy, während er Hühnchen von Kentucky Fried Chicken gegessen hat, von John von Ronald McDonald, John Filcus Cuth, kurz JFK, erschossen wurde. Und der genau so heißt, wie der Attentäter, der Abraham Lincoln erschossen hat. Genau hundert Jahre später. Genau. Das ist ein Zufall? Das ist ein sogenannter Z to the U to the F to the A to the LL Zufall. Wir können heute nicht alle Probleme lösen, das machen wir nächste Woche. Die meisten sind Zufall. Die meisten sind Zufall. Also, ich meine, wenn natürlich auch eine interessante Serie so was, ich denke an Sherlock Holmes, der sagt, Moment mal, der Mörder ist Florist. Ne, Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich es aber gespoilert, Entschuldigung, vergesst es nochmal bitte. Hugo ist Florist. Ist Hugo der Mörder? Das Opfo, das Opfo, jetzt hast du mich komplett rausgebracht, ja, Hugo ist der Mörder. Wollt ihr eine Erklärung oder? Ja gut. Der Film gibt sich so wenig Mühe, Spangen aufzubauen. Gab es keinen anderen Take? Das war der einzige Take, wenn es gab. Mach es doch mal, aber mit weniger Versprechern. Okay. Das will ich mal am Set. Ich will eigentlich immer mal, ich will eigentlich Regisseur werden, um mal den Satz. Du hast doch schon oft genug du doch schon oft genug, Stefan. Du hast doch schon oft genug Leute rumkommandiert. Professionell, um dann zu sagen, mach es doch mal besser, bitte einmal. Wir machen noch mal einen Take, aber einmal besser, danke. Einmal, um dann zu sehen, wie jemand denkt, what an ass. Können wir noch mal einen Take machen, wo du besser Schauspieler hast? Können wir noch mal einmal machen, wo du ein bisschen weniger hölzern und schrecklich bist? Genau, noch mal einen mit weniger künstlich, bitte. Das ist gemein. Kann ich aber nämlich nicht verkneifen, einmal das aus Spaß zu machen. Aus Spaß, aber es wäre auch ein bisschen Ernsthaftigkeit dabei. Denn in jedem Witz schwingt ja auch ein bisschen Wahrheit mit. Das sind schöne letzte Worte von Stefan Tietze für diese Folge. Möchte du sonst noch was sagen? Das war's für diese Woche. Haut rein, wir sind das Podcast-Ufo. Wir heben ab. Wir sind das Podcast-Ufo. Mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia mia Hot Cosmopo, cheers! And it's also a worst bird production.